la science entourant donc les campagnes
électorales l'importance des données du
profilage des lecteurs est bien sûr un
sujet de prédilection abordé avec nos
stratèges
on les retrouve vous voyez cette semaine
pas le luxe de les avoir en studio avec
moi si le rythme de la campagne qui les
mène un peu partout car le bélanger
conseiller principal de thomas mulcair
vous êtes à vancouver catherine loubier
conseillère de stephen harper pour le
québec vous êtes ottawa et robert
hosselet conseiller de justin trudeau à
montréal catherine je commencerai
peut-être avec vous il ya un élément
dans le reportage de marc qui frappe les
esprits c'est cette idée que dans la
dernière campagne
cette connaissance de l'électorat ces
données ont fait la différence dans 40
compte et ça change tout la façon
finalement de faire campagne pour un
parti comme le vôtre
très bien dre que un parti politique ça
demain ça demeure une coalition des
lecteurs évidemment avec les données on
est capable c'est très spécialisés c'est
l'heure du numérique dans des campagnes
dans les outils de marketing on est
capable d'aller très loin
par ailleurs je pense qu'il faut pas
oublier que la fameuse poignée de main
traditionnelle où on regarde les
lecteurs dans les yeux et très
importante aussi
et donc que rien qui remplace le terrain
c'est donc une combinaison je devrais d2
et il ya certaines parties de la
population qui sont au moins sur les
réseaux sociaux qui sont moins
disponibles pour répondre à des appels
téléphoniques comme par exemple et les
personnes âgées et autres couches de la
population donc c'est vraiment une
combinaison des deux pieds rien qui
remplace la poignée de main karl quand
on parle de
de ces données ça va avec la poignée de
main en fait du pointage en faisant du
porte à porte et cetera
oui ça fait sortir le vote mais est ce
que ça a changé la façon dont les partis
politiques développent leurs programmes
électoraux n'ont pas seulement au niveau
du développement des programmes mais
certainement au niveau des messages qui
sont véhiculés et or on sait mieux quels
sont les intérêts des électeurs et on
peut cibler les peurs du programme qui
les intéresse c'est la grande différence
avec le pointage traditionnel diop 20 30
40 ans ou fondamentalement les gens
cherchent à trouver de quel côté les
électeurs pencher maintenant on le multi
tube de données à savoir quelles sont
leurs intérêts quelles sont leurs
préoccupations et comment on peut
véhiculer un message auprès d'eux qui
les intéressent et donc ça c'est pour
parler du bon sujet dans le bon compte
et on parlera pas par exemple de
garderie dans un comté de 75% des gens
aux pompes ont peu d'enfants c'est comme
ça cette manifestion le terrain mais on
peut cibler le 25 pour cent de ce
complot qui ceux qui s'intéressent aux
garderies c'est ça la beauté de la chose
c'est qu'on ne peut plus on est on est
on n'a plus besoin d'évacuer un sujet
par compte et on peut cibler les
électeurs selon les intérêts qui les
préoccupent personnellement robert
quand on regarde les plateformes
électorales par ailleurs quand on
regarde l'histoire la politique dans les
dernières années on a quand même
l'impression que la politique se fait à
coups de petites promesses bien ciblés
vous vous en voyez pas un lien cette
connaissance scientifique et le fait de
développer des plateformes plus
fragmentaire d'une certaine façon
ben je lui poserai un peu autrement je
pense que dans chaque élection certain
nombre d'électeurs qui sont indécis que
chaque partie peut aller chercher et
c'est vraiment ces électeurs là qu'on
veut aller parler qu'on veut convaincre
avec nos idées avec nos plateformes et
c'est là où on peut être plus précis en
sachant exactement ce que ces
électeurs-là les indices y cherche
ce qu'ils veulent voir dans les
plateformes électorales à sarlat
politique plus professionnelle si on
veut se professionnalise les politiques
et ça nous permet nous d'avoir des
messages plus ciblés et c'est ce qui
fait catherine que quand on entend
souvent combien de faux nouvelles on
entends me sur un peu par la sa base sa
base monsieur harper il la connaît à
cause de ça justement où effectivement
la rétroaction et dans les deux sens on
en sait plus sur eux mais on peut leur
parler de manière beaucoup plus précise
maintenant effectivement maintenant à
l'autre en jus que dominés peut-être un
peu la campagne en courant de la
dernière semaine ce sont tous ces
candidats tous ces ratés sur les médias
sociaux et bien sûr les chefs qui ont dû
se défaire de certains candidats
défendre leurs méthodes de recrutement
peut être écouté après monsieur trudeau
parce que la liste des ratés y en a
quelques-uns on entend monsieur trudeau
qui faisait référence à joey davis en
colombie-britannique qui elle a eu des
propos controversés sur les vertus de la
marijuana ultime du taux chez les
conservateurs faisait des vidéos
insolence téléphonique assez controversé
aussi du côté du npd vous n'êtes pas en
reste il ya des candidats qui ont été
rejetées pour des positions passées la
dernière en liste qui est toujours avec
vous je crois c'est catherine soit en
pis pour son langage ordurier sur les
réseaux sociaux une photo de son mari
avec une arme de poing est chez terra
première question et aucun parti
politique qui aiment se faire ce que
monsieur trudeau monsieur harper ont eu
à faire cette semaine
mais est ce que ça change quelque chose
ces controverses là je commencerai par
vous garde écouter les médias sociaux
sont des beaux outils de communication
de masse avec lesquels on peut véhiculer
son message à des niveaux non
traditionnels
le problème vient au niveau des
individus et là ça peut devenir un
cauchemar pour les organisateurs
politiques parce que ça peut faire
déraper la campagne les gens utilisent
les médias sociaux lorsqu'ils n'ont pas
d'ambition politique
un peu comme ils sont dans leur salon
pas avec leurs amis port avec un voisin
dix ans après n'importe quoi et des
choses qui semblent sans conséquences
lorsqu'on à 18 ou 19 ans si on a des
ambitions politiques peuvent nous
rattraper
une marée effectivement ce qu'on a vu
dans les dernières semaines on voit
qu'une certaine certaines sans une
polarisation de cette recherche
d'informations et on va même jusqu'à
voir allez voir que vous avez mentionné
dans les deux passes et des familles
mais des candidats alors ça va très très
loin et c'est un outil qui comme je les
dis peut être très utile aux partis
politiques mais peut aussi être émises
mais si les médias sont capables de les
faire ces recherches là que vos
adversaires paul politique ou s'ils sont
capables de les faire
est ce que ça veut pas dire qu'il va
falloir que les partis politiques
pour phil leurs méthodes pour
approuvé des candidats catherine je
pense qu'il ya un peu des deux
effectivement le quand un candidat
remplit son cahier de candidats comme on
dit dans le langage c'est un geste très
important c'est un candidat qui veut
servir les canadiens dans sa
circonscription alors il a la
responsabilité de dévoiler ou de rendre
fait de ce qu'ils pensent pourrait lui
causer des problèmes et s'il ne fait pas
ça va le poursuivre dans le futur
maintenant oui les parties ont aussi une
responsabilité de faire un certain
nombre de recherches mais il incombe
aussi aux candidats de le faire et vous
savez quand on ouvre un compte facebook
et un petit bébé avec une date de
naissance
ça prend tout son sens quand il ya des
propos qui sont souvent pris parfois
même hors contexte mais mais c'est la
vie sur facebook et mis dans le journal
le matin le candidat souvent reste reste
surpris et c'est le public les électeurs
qui en fin de compte ce sont les juges à
savoir est-ce que c'est allé trop loin
et est ce que les excuses d'un candidat
ou ou le fait que ça fait plusieurs
années que ça a été publié sur facebook
c'est assez pour pour réparer la
situation est juste en terminant vous
savez facebook c'est la première source
d'information des des gens des électeurs
donc alors c'est c'est tout de même
important d'aller voir ce qui s'est dit
ce qui se publiait sur les pages
facebook me roberge on prend le problème
à l'envers est ce que c'est juste de
faire payer un candidat aujourd'hui pour
quelque chose qui aurait dit 5 4 ans
dans un contexte complètement différent
c'est une bonne question en fait ce
jugement qu'il faut poser dans chacun
des cas et des fois il arrive c'est
toujours le chef en bout de ligne qui
décide et nous on conseille là-dessus
mais je pense qu'en bout de ligne
chacun est différent il ya des bio des
fois où effectivement ceux des
proportions inacceptables qu'on les ait
dit à 10 ans 12 euros
une semaine sont inacceptables donc on
ne peut pas les accepter il ya d'autres
fois où il ya un contexte différent qui
fait qu'une personne a dit une chose
comme kiki regrettable mais qui pend soi
un scandale et là on peut dire écoutez à
ce moment là c'était peut-être correct
que la personne ait fait le commentaire
on va lui pardonner la personne de
s'excuser de terreur tout et tout dépend
évidemment de l'ampleur de ce que la
personne a dit alors une question
jugement à chaque dans chacun des cas ou
trois jours merci d'avoir été des nôtres
et on se retrouve la semaine prochaine
pour parler entre autres débats merci
ouah